quand on a fait notre vérif sur les
scooters interdit dans les pistes
cyclables
tous les jours ils croisent des scooters
électriques que c'est pas interdit cette
interview on a reçu plusieurs courriels
des gens voulaient savoir ce que les
cyclistes dans le droite vers et ce qui
est interdit
alors on ne vérifie
[Musique]
d'abord il n'ya aucune limite pour
l'alcool au guidon un cycliste qui a
pris la boisson n'est pas tenu de
respecter le point 0,20 par contre si la
personne est ivre si elle représente un
danger elle peut être arrêtée pour les
bicyclettes électriques par contre la
limite 2.08 s'applique à ce qu'il y ait
un moteur ceci dit peu importe la
situation circuler avec de l'alcool à la
main cette interview l'autre chose qui
nous a frappés dans notre recherche
le cellulaire au guidon n'est pas
interdit dire que j'ai fait la morale à
tous mes amis qui se demanderaient père
du vélo sachez par contre qu'une
obligation légale de tenir le guidon
article 477 du code de la sécurité
routière une infraction qui peut vous
valoir 15 à 30 dollars d'amendé à
bénédicte a aussi en sont interdits 30 à
60 dollars d'amande circuler sur le
trottoir c'est interdit pour un cycliste
à moins que l'endroit soit dangereux ou
à moins qu'ils aient une indication
contraire
l'année dernière les policiers de
montréal ont donné mille contraventions
pour des vélos sur les trottoirs lorsque
vous roulez sur la chaussée vous avez
l'obligation d'être à droite sauf
lorsque vous êtes à une intersection
vous voulez qu'on vérifie quelque chose
écrivez nous
[Musique]